[Music]
good job ila good job i'm very proud of
you she's been killing it today hey guys
brand new podcast uh at the end of it my
wife LeAnn is here she's not speaking
into the mic she's not a professional
she is gonna her and I are going to do
so you're generating toilets ki by the
way we're going to do a black sails
recap that finale was last week today's
podcast very quickly before i get into
details I want to make sure you know
that my buddy Steve Byrne and Gary
cannon both my friends came into this
podcast Steve Byrne has a showtime
special airing this friday it'll be on
showtime all month you'll catch it
non-stop all month it's called tell the
damn joke and airs at nine p.m. this
friday on showtime I've known Steve for
almost as long as I've been doing
stand-up is one of my close friends we
have a great conversation I just want to
make sure that you know is to watch his
special the DVR it and and those little
steps you take to just share a tweet or
share something on Facebook or or take
the minute to repost is is bits from the
post on Instagram they really mean a
great deal they really genuinely do a
share is better than a view these days
tell the damn joke this friday on
showtime at 9pm steve byrne gary cannon
real quick I want to talk to them our
sponsor I got this sponsor and at first
I thought I don't want to mess around
with a sponsor that doesn't apply to me
and then I realized how I'm gonna make
today's sponsor ziprecruiter apply to me
are you hiring you know so funny I've
been one to hire for a long time I've
been looking for a production assistant
to work with me for a long time do you
know where to post these jobs to find
the best candidate honestly I don't I
had no [ __ ] idea I just set it out
loud on my podcast posting your jobs in
one place isn't enough to find the
qualifying candidate no [ __ ] I've been
saying it out loud on the podcast I get
it if you want to find the perfect i er
need to post all post your job on all
the top job sites and now you can with
ziprecruiter com you can post your job
to 200 plus job sites including social
media networks like Facebook and Twitter
all with a single click finding find
candidates in any city or industry
nationwide that's what I'm looking for
just one post and watch your qualified
candidates role in the zip recruiters
easy-to-use interface i will be using
ziprecruiter to look for this production
assistant who you will hear on this
podcast they will be hired through
ziprecruiter no juggling emails or calls
to your office quickly screen candidates
rate them and hire the right person fast
find out why ziprecruiter has been used
by Fortune 100 companies and thousands
of small and medium-sized businesses are
you sure its fortune 100 yeah top
fortune 500 miss fortune 100 oh sorry
i've never heard of fortune 100 yeah
well it's the top 100 who only cares
about the bottom four hundred and right
now my listeners can post jobs on
ziprecruiter for free by going to
ziprecruiter calm / bert cast that
ziprecruiter calm / Bert cast one more
time try it for free go to ziprecruiter
dot-com / Bert cast and see if you can
beat me there because i will be posting
tonight to zip recruiter for free by
going to ziprecruiter calm / berkrot
[ __ ] that ziprecruiter calm /
forecast to look for someone to help me
with my podcast and all the production
stuff I'm doing why am i doing it
honestly this is the one part that
sailed me told me no juggling emails or
calls to your office quickly screen
candidates rate them and hire the right
person fast ladies and gentlemen you've
heard me talk about this forever on this
podcast go to ziprecruiter com you can
do it for free to the ashbrook test I
hope that was stylized enough now I got
to go to zip code early n I know oh very
exciting I should have said my tour
dates first
real quick tour dates are all selling
out very quickly I will Denver is I
think found out I think Denver sold out
nuts in August so but we're gonna add
another show I don't know August that's
an August and it's already sold out yeah
holy cow I know yeah and so um I
honestly I think there's like eight
tickets left and then they're going
we're going to add another show we
haven't added it yet so if you're still
in denver you can go run and get tickets
I think they just called today Detroit
is also sold out wait Detroit is sold
out to judge Entwistle doubt don't act
so surprised why I'm supposed to be a
big shot yeah but I can't keep up with
it um wiseguys salt lake city thursday
is definitely not sold out i'm going to
be of wiseguys the thirteenth fourteenth
and fifteenth of april stand up live in
huntsville alabama get your tickets now
though that will sell out as will the
wild west comedy festival the 21st 22nd
and i fought the 23rd but it's not on my
calendar maybe it's just the 21st 22nd
that would be nice i'm doing a call in
sick to work show listen i'm going to be
doing a live call in sick to work show
podcast I'm going to change the format
of it this time and see if it can be
more fun I kind of want to tell you who
my guests are because I think you're
getting really excited it's going to be
[ __ ] awesome and I may have three
guests I may have a guy who's been
disappeared in Asia for a while on the
podcast I can't say his name but he's
going to be reappeared he's going to be
reappeared from Asia hopefully that
weekend little know and and then two
other comics bucket Nate bargatze and
Sean Patton I'm so excited Sean if you
haven't he's they're both they're both
hilarious comics and we're just going to
do a live party podcast i think thursday
morning at like thursday morning at like
noon or one o'clock I think and we will
be drinking it's going to get fun and
it's going to get crazy and and we're
going to be doing it for something
bigger but I'm going to release it on
this podcast so it should be fun
hopefully I can do more of those and
make those colin62 work shows live
events like that
um yuk yuk's Canada in Calvary the 27th
28th 29th Detroit sold out Cincinnati's
getting close to sold out so get your
tickets at liberty township I'm only
there two nights for shows crapshoot
comedy festival in vegas on the
nineteenth and Bisbee i love just saying
this biz be sold out in a record [ __ ]
time I swear to God chili posted it it's
me and Stanhope doing a swap cast chili
posted it and no sooner did he posted
that it sold out that is more a
testament of doug stanhope than not me i
can promise you that that in fact that
it's like a 25 feet Peter so all right
today's podcast I've already announced
it but I will say one more time if
you're still listening to this
long-winded intro at seven minutes I've
done worse both of these guys I know
very well I've worked Gary a bunch gary
was the warm-up guy for Steve and Gary
and Steve have a podcast called called
gentleman's dojo Steve I've known since
in we were in New York we toured for
together on Jamison's comedy yes also
had a show called Sullivan sons on TBS
for three years and I think that was
what I was most fascinated to talk to
him about because he dealt with its
success and its cancellation and then
rebounded now has a showtime special
that airs friday at 9pm enough of the
ads Burt guys listen to the podcast my
guest Gary cannon and Steve Byrne
[Music]
hello that one's hot go ahead Steve LOL
0 1 2 3 go all right yeah yeah you right
there kkkk get a little hot [ __ ] you're
coming in hot okay I think we're all
songs okay um 666 Eric uh guys welcome
to my dojo wow you don't waste any time
this just right in this place is awesome
but I'm music thank you yeah this isn't
like a man this is more study this
thing's file of this one yeah squirt
what was this originally this from it
was a woodworking shop so the garage is
next to us and there is a door there's a
door going out that way this was all
closed off and there was a door
connecting it to the garage and then
they closed off that door and then open
this up I mean I'll put it in
perspective when we got this house and
we had looked to buying doors like that
I couldn't afford those doors yeah like
I remember when we did I was like I'll
get some french doors and I was like oh
I can't afford those doors now yeah and
so I was like they spent like a hundred
eighty-six thousand dollars on this room
sorry yep wow this is this the kinda
funny bone built no no I didn't I didn't
I don't know we even so normally they
they make you um they make you do you
have to like to all the demo you've got
to raise the foundation get older you've
got to get it up to specs and get it all
that's how they do these cooking tour
the building shows is you do all this
[ __ ] and then they come in and put the
finishing touches on oh they're only
there for three days but they came
because a little of this is gossip but
adam richman from man vs food was
supposed to get 100k and and it didn't
work out it was super complicated and
they called him [ __ ] uh-huh no no it
was like it was like they were thinking
together at enrichment oh yeah molest
them
I get a little frisky sometimes what are
you gonna do I said I mean come on
you're not so crazy though I knew it
once comics it used to take their dicks
out and just for jerking off one day
this I I know Adam impress them I side
with him I really don't I mean because
the story that he tells my i'm glad i've
been making the joke and I like Adam so
I have known out of her i say it's a
great dude I don't know it just it seems
like it's one of those he got a little
rail relations were yeah where they can
ask you out I think if you really done
something bad he would have never said
what he said to the cops look I got a
little frisky yeah yeah there ya like it
[ __ ] happens anyway a drunk a little
crazy the server and you really raised
someone you don't go what yeah yeah I
mean that was the deal to server invited
him back after the show so I mean that's
you know kind of thing about the whole
thing yeah but and it stinks that the
word rape just doesn't have there's
there's not like a rape light you know
like there's not look it's just rape and
then you're like oh [ __ ] rape huh
right now is what did you hear the stuff
that came out about Bill O'Reilly today
and all that [ __ ] about what he was
saying to these women I mean so it's
pretty crazy about you know this d
sexual harassment suit I was hoping you
would know because I don't know just try
to look smart by saying today 13 million
dollars to cover up yes lawsuit for like
payout lawsuits but but they have these
these messages these dialogue messages
between him and these women about you
know you're gonna meet me at the hotel
you're going to get in the shower while
they order room service then I'm going
to come in and you're going to have your
back turned towards me and it's just
like I shut it off then because I came
but you know I don't remember specifics
about his whole house is just French
doors so this shall listen this was paid
for by they also adam richman wow not
the nothing it causes that's a comic as
we gonna do you could derail every time
I don't bring about embracement Adam
Richman uh didn't get one he was
supposed to get one so they have money
for two of us oh wow and then his didn't
come through it was really difficult it
was in Brooklyn he didn't necessarily
have a place for a man cave it would
have been like a renovation and then
they were going to build him a trailer
it was like all these are the things and
then the end there
like [ __ ] it let's just give it all to
Bert allow and so I got for both of the
shows i got all the stuff they would
allow hence the two TVs the whiner
fridge you're in the kegerator thank you
notice there's all those doubles of
everything in the air yeah what's this
yeah it so it's uh do you need two TVs
in here no no no it's gone up a bit I'll
tell you the other thing is I can't take
naps in here yeah I've never been able
to sleep in here like if that's what
stinks my speciality and you can't jack
off in here because your beauty and
those well I could take a nap in here
the minute I walked in here I saw
comfortably dumb and I was like I'm
taking up wait a minute the reason why
we're here is to promote TV special on
friday so i can add one show today yeah
there's where your nap comes in verse
test this room on friday night yeah we
were last year what did you name your
special tell a damn joke tell the dams a
call back to what Jess says my wife when
I I asked her permission to do a joke
about her ass which is a little big
bigger but yeah yeah that's what I
called it so do you do the joke about
there's a joke that you were working on
a long time ago and I'm assuming it's
got to be in the special but I think of
honestly probably once a week and that
is uh how many [ __ ] movies are going
to make about the Holocaust oh that was
in my second hour yeah that was in Bern
identity but yeah I feel like yeah ok I
want to go pitch a movie called the
Titanic yeah oh yeah yeah but from two
other ppl precisely yeah I thought of in
calling you tell the damned yogi should
have been calling it tell a damn joke
tell a beb's or alive my twitter feed
loan up right now what I don't need any
Eminem's could you do you want mmm
Christmas whole [ __ ] you know I don't
write so many [ __ ] yeah I've got to
the girls the girls can get away with
putting candy in here and it doesn't and
there's just like the like it stands man
cave is candy in there and then they
just come back I'll is the one she's got
a [ __ ]
problem she's got all my my low reward
standards she's like you would but with
booze yeah she's the way I am with booze
I was gonna we were in a this isn't
probably that i can tell you when this
was i let just been born this was ten
years ago 10 years ago Steve and I were
doing the Jameson tour okay when we were
we were in similar case in two weeks by
the way yeah do you write I don't know
if you remember this but Gardell and I
were like fascinated we're blown away
that before you going this tour there's
the first time I think it was like the
the first time we're all going yeah so
Jameson send you a case of jameson oh
wow and two weeks later we go on tour
and so we're all at the first gig and
Burt's like you already finished mine
you guys I'm like I haven't even opened
it I drank a bottle the first time it
was [ __ ] I was like a difficult case
believes dude or we'd bet we did that
first day together was in um it was in
seattle at that last place where they
had anything i was a christian yeah and
uh and and he was like he was like yeah
no dirty jokes my opening joke was
Jameson tastes so good it [ __ ] tastes
like jamis and I'd have bruised knees
and uh and Allen [ __ ] freaked out
allen went off the rails oh my god
that's why Alan holy [ __ ] yeah yeah that
was a [ __ ] really fun toward remember
what time we found out to that girl
[ __ ] Penn & Teller yeah yeah she bang
both of them knows you guys were one of
them nick griffin who did not speak at
all like my was like tell her tell her
the girl even tell her of our trophy he
found out that she [ __ ] with a big one
with everyone that is Penn Jillette yeah
Penn Jillette and he lost his [ __ ]
mind you sucked his gay you pietra [ __ ]
like it was the funniest that was the
funnest that was a really fun tour you
seem to have always done that like had
made touring enjoyable where's my story
now right now he tore together quite a
bit yeah but I've been able to do that
I've never been able to lock down like a
guy that tours with me yeah or even like
like Rosa Mercedes like how you got a
tour of someone it makes it so much
fought more fun I think for anybody
that's going to open for you it's tough
to keep up with you because i was
literally i'm not making this up I've
had so many conversations the last few
weeks I work with Brad Williams last
weekend in Cleveland and just so many
people your name has come up and we're
all like fascinated it's just like we
don't know how you you do it like with
with like the consumption of alcohol but
then to put on a great show and not like
like when i slur I'm done I'm just like
I'm done but it seems like that never
happens to you is that true there I've
never seen you slur and I've been out
with you on nights where you're just
like you are [ __ ] on fire and you
keep it going and there's nobody more
fun to hang out with I'm just like I
think back on all those times we r on
Jan I'm like was there ever a breaking
point cuz you never learn it was like it
was crazy well I don't I I think I think
I don't look as drunk I don't act as
drunk as I am yeah I think once I get
drunk I just go to bed but I don't
really get that might get pretty [ __ ]
hammered those I remember telling you I
remember you and I were the we started
doing those contests after the show Oh
God in Minnesota he is like bar games
yeah it would just get the heat Bert you
know he invites the whole crap here
afterward this is such this is like this
is probably exactly what my therapist
would say a direct effect of my low
self-esteem um I knew that my bar bills
were through the roof that the people
were coming to my shows were drinking
like [ __ ] lunatics and Tony baldino
one time said to me you know another for
nothing if you bring them out to the bar
tonight and you can keep him here until
two in the morning I'll give you your
bonus and I was like really he goes yet
you'll make me an extra three grand and
bar sales I wouldn't have had Wow and so
I was like done so I and an anything
that might the improv our yacumo the
Impaler don't let him go out let him
keep those drinks so I started doing
that then then we went we went to
Minneapolis one time me and Steve well
know where we chicago again weird in
chicago and i said let's do a game we
did a it was a beat Burt we had to the
videos online Steve shot it and hosted
it and I said
made everyone hold pints like in in a
crucifix position yeah that's right yeah
and see how who can hold him up the
longest what they didn't know was that
that was the only exercise I ever did
was side arm raises on my shoulders and
for deceivingly athletic yeah because
you are I've been golfing with you we
used to play home run derby our thing
was we used to go Derby was the [ __ ]
best the [ __ ] greatest but Bert
[ __ ] straight up bombs I'm talking
bombing it not just over the fence like
that oh he's like way past the fence I
think like you and rena ZZ had stroke
because when is easy actually played but
I mean there was like a pure you know
like Chris Farley it was so funny
goofily tell that dude was pretty
athletic oh yeah I'm not saying you're
like Farley but I know you're saying but
I know you're saying but you're like a
genuine dude driving a golf ball just
brute strength I was I was always
fascinated by that that's so interesting
i'm equally as fascinated by your
there's this thing you have where i'm
like dying to know what your marketing
plan is for the for your our special
because you're someone that has it and
he's gonna watch it on friday yeah he's
also calling in to 740 a.m. later this
week over to the school closing a good
spot with is this your fourth special
form oh yeah nice yeah but how was yours
received on showtime and did you see a
bump or there's like I so many comics
I've talked to they talk about how even
like this round I know talk shows I
couldn't get a one talk show and they
said there's so many hour specials now
it's almost like the Booker's they don't
give a [ __ ] now that's what they could
have been telling me no that's later
that's even what JP a trophy buck
related and I'm friends with a guy and I
was like yeah I guess so noted that
couple nights ago at the Viper Room
every comic I brought up to the state
said mention my our special Wow yeah and
a lot of these people weren't even
comics [ __ ] you can I tell you how many
I'm irate without any chef of [ __ ] TV
shows oh my god guys I got into the
entertainment business to get on TV what
[ __ ] like from a culinary school yeah
and what you just got a cooking show but
how was it received this time on on that
platform uh the machine would by the way
which was great not okay very candidly
not not huge okay it was middle of the
list of the specials they released that
year yeah middle of a list now granted
the ones ahead of it or like Martin
Lawrence they were bigger ones yeah was
middle list it wasn't like it was the
one of the top dvr'd specials oh it's
great mom that they released last year
yeah but and so and so I like I I came
out and I didn't see a bump at all of
November all December but then I got the
right to release clips from the special
and I released four clips and the and
they all went semi viral yeah so the
machine story went viral like legit like
25 million views and then like everyone
else got like 5 million six million
views one off facebook are you releasing
clips yeah I do that dumb that one but
yeah do that sooner as opposed to later
yeah because I guy started writing
started releasing I'm like I just didn't
even think about it now like [ __ ] in
december or just released one and then
that and that changed my touring right
now I haven't had I haven't had a show
that hasn't been sold out well January
Wow but and it's just because of that
[ __ ] machine clip and machine clip
the Rachael Ray clip of the two ones
that what happen but I the show the
right before that nothing I mean like
yeah I remember the room and Dayton
papered the room in Toledo gave her the
room and I mean for my new year's eve
show I got was paper that was like yeah
and then that was all right after the
special then that once I clip went viral
then people started looking for the
special or find the special that and
some guy bootlegged it and put it online
and he titled it um funny naked man
talking's I did it with my shirt off and
that got like a million views yeah I
think I just like I wish I had just let
everyone bootleg it the day it comes out
to go everyone [ __ ] put it on youtube
I don't give you [ __ ] yeah and i would
say that to you i would say that
out of my fans if you can get ahold of
steves special put it on [ __ ] YouTube
some people to find it yeah because that
was you know Showtime aired it a lot um
they air the [ __ ] out of those things
how good but uh but yeah you got it like
you got a hope for Ralphie May told me
you got to hope for a snow storm or
something like the day it comes out yeah
yeah then it says a snowstorm you get
everybody numbers idea I try to get it
on in the winter but to no avail and by
the way a lot of people don't know that
some guy remember this this weekend in
Cleveland he called he he called it out
he goes hey um Romeo horsecock prison
fucktoy never cry sure I go [ __ ]
right and I had done some podcast before
I talking here at me talk about it when
I did the burn identity at the end Bobby
Lee comes out and for their so Scotty to
do that right Christ sure was supposed
to come out and do it because we we just
come off a torn for Jamison and he had
come up with Romeo horse [ __ ] and sauce
and um and our prison [ __ ] when I he
would just say those things randomly and
stuff and you got it on the bottle of
jameson I thought it was the [ __ ]
funny oh wow so that's how I always had
those two names from Christ sure yeah
that uh that was fun I'm never lost his
hated it he hated that we did that he
was like you guys gonna [ __ ] hurt
somebody you guys are gonna get sued and
we were like then we're like what are
they that happened yeah I'm just doing
it nobody's ever gotten hurt yeah we had
it that was a [ __ ] that was fun they
said you guys got to watch Steve last
Passover what Steve would do is he'd
close no I closed the shows and Stephen
would just come out in the middle of my
side toward the end of my said it was a
great way to get me off stage two
because I would go along so you could
just walk out in the middle of my set
and just go hey you want to do this and
I'm like all right and then what do you
do i do have anything big that you're
closing your shows with now no I mean I
stopped doing sauce party for a while
and then Colin Jost used to open for me
he's like do you still doing I'm like no
he's like you got to bring it out he's
like it's such a fun inclusive joyous
way and the crowd just kind of goes to
another level sometimes at the end of
the shows and I'm just like maybe I
should do it you know what somebody's
like a revered as Jose is like you
should do it I so I started doing it
again and it is a blast but I mean there
are certain people that just gel with it
and you always gel with it later comes
off you always had these boots on and
with all these low kicks it was so funny
or some guys you bring up on stage
you're worried about them and then they
turned it on yeah I'm so damn funny I
mean it's really you and there's there's
nights four we'll go into the show and
Steve will say I'm not feeling it
tonight don't want to do sausage party
and I'll know in the back of my head
once he gets rolling he'll want to close
with it so i'll have the song cued up
and it'll be like carries the song ready
and I'll be like yeah it's really funny
just cuz I know once we get rolling
never want to do a stupid touring now
together five yeah turn to a solid
Andrea know it started in the opening
for the Sullivan & Son tour back in 1
2013 and then once this once the tour
yeah once the show got canceled we had
such a good report he just came on the
road with me and then there was the
relationship and him just constantly
[ __ ] on me and had never having
accomplished anything it is correct here
and I was like this is a fun dynamic and
we met with Alan started doing the
gentleman's dojo again on all things
comedy and that was that's been fun and
spent a little over a year yeah and you
did one of our first I think we the
first one called in you calm enough Lane
in college we're not you worry we're
going somewhere and I remember that
you're like I'm at the airport on my
click you hear what I got I think that
was my first question go worry what bar
you at what he's right yeah you were
going somewhere I just whether you were
called in like early in the morning yeah
yeah so will you guys do are you
dropping out once a week we do it once a
week yeah we just interviewed Corey
Feldman because we went to a show and it
was [ __ ] like we all went there like
me Porter glebe tone Bell Gareth
Reynolds were just and you know Gareth
was just here Duran right the greatest
she okay here yes and we went there
thinking okay this is going to be an
absolute shitshow we're here to just
watch this beautiful disaster unfold in
front of us yeah and outcomes Corey
Feldman giving it a hundred and ten
percent on the tables high-fiving people
thank you so much for coming out this
means so much to me doing another tune
thank you guys it's Sunday I can't thank
enough you're part of this special night
for me it's the first night of the tour
with the angels you're just like this
dude [ __ ] Jetson I mean rights would
make money oh yeah and
and then we interview the nicest guy the
nicest guy considering all the things
he's gone through I read his book you
know as like a joke and that i read i
was like i kind of feel bad but you know
with all the child molestations nothing
sorry yeah molested yeah yeah I mean
he's the one that he's the one guy
that's come out and kind of exposed this
Hollywood pedophilia ring that's going
on he was [ __ ] on our Michael Jackson
yeah Michael Jackson [ __ ] up he didn't
know he said the delay he didn't he
didn't think that any of that stuff was
true I think he and the thing about
Michael that you always hear is that he
just wanted to be a kid so bad he just
want to hang out with kids and it's
[ __ ] up as perverted as it sounds to
us it's like there's a kid that's been
famous since he was six and he just he
lives in a different universe so that
was always it was funny because when we
can play Corey Feldman called in he said
hey I'm just getting to madison
wisconsin or green bay yeah i don't have
a lot of time that he was like really
trying to brush things off and we end up
talking for like 45 minutes yeah ended
up having a bus so we're doing this
Facebook live show that he's doing and
he's doing like this telethon for four
hours if you want to do it it's it's
like on a Monday it's from it's like
from nuna for something and he'll do
songs and then he has like different
friends coming through and you just come
in you'll get a time slot and you just
kind of you can talk with them or you
can do stand-up whatever you want but
it's just one of those things where it's
like I grew up watching all these guys
movies and it's like it seems like a
good dude yeah we were we I've first met
him probably 15 years ago oh yeah yeah
and but he would never know who I am but
I've seen I've run into him a bunch
because I we used to do the same type of
television badly enough I think he was a
guest on The X show a lot oh that's and
so and so but the girls have watched
Goonies and so we're at this [ __ ]
laser tag place and I see Corey Feldman
and I go yo Georgia I go that's the guy
from Goonies and she's like put oh my
god what's he doing a dying here she
goes she goes is he like super famous
now and I was like I mean yeah but no
he's not he's like he is not doing
really acting anymore yeah she was like
wait
how is it even possible and I was like
yeah that is kind of curious oh yeah
like I'm sure if you saw Goonies you're
like this kid's gonna be a star sure
yeah that's so cool that it was fun
totally fun and he's doing like Sean
Pasadena and another show i think in LA
in like two weeks and i might go and
it's just like it's funny when you got
to that show you were like this is going
to be a joke completely i can't wait to
just start goofing on it and it was just
not anything to what you thought it
would be was not I wanted to I wanted to
make fun of it I couldn't I was like
this is a very performer and we actually
today Steve wasn't there she had to do a
separate podcast at all things calming
studio but today we interviewed Howie
Mandel for a podcast route which is
great he was awesome will progress did
you do to the not our gentlemen's dojo
yeah but you couldn't break away to join
me excited to do the Howie podcast at
his production office in Van Nuys ok so
we went there kind of mobile and then
Steve stayed in the studio to interview
another guest and we have four coming up
who will Burke he's one of the director
writer directors on Kimmel and we we had
last week we had to reschedule I just I
i couldn't reschedule a the reins on
this young okay which is kind of you
know yeah I wish I there's a lot of
regrets I have about how I started my
podcasts and what is what is it might
like I'd love to have done it with
another person it would have made things
so [ __ ] these you can now now now I'm so
now I'm so I would like that because I
would have liked to he'll have helped in
the lifting process right like someone
booking guess that's the hardest part is
getting to a book getting people booked
so funny i got like three different
people reaching out for you to me yeah
and i was like at one point rachel from
all the comedy reached out to me and I
was like I go why just tell him to call
me like yeah definitely he's always on
my podcast just having to call me and
she was like well I'll just set it up
and I was like okay yeah even today I
like I gotta talk to Carrie and it was
like we esteem coming like he wants to
bring his dog especially my [ __ ] on
Davis but what we was going to hear this
in [ __ ] just for you we were saying
something funny because I think Steve
and I were doing the podcast we're
really excited about it at first we were
just putting different shows together we
interviewed the guy who was in that
movie Atari game over he created
that game yars revenge but also created
ET yeah like you know so we were doing
all these different things would get
Theo Fleury on with all of these
different things and then Steve and I
working on a podcast one Monday and we
just had on a comic stranded comic and I
remember at the end of it we both look
at each other like so we were just both
so bored you me were just like it was
just another comic what's your favorite
we're on the play which were just like
would be great if we just really
expanded this and do more of what we
want to do rather than because it's just
like you said with the bookings you had
somebody help with that it's so much
easier rather than it's monday we gotta
fill studio time someone help it but i
I've been doing my long enough that I
know what I know what works and what I
yeah yeah like I know what my fans like
like number one they love two guests
yeah they love to guess if we're
drinking they love that even more yeah
um they love three our podcasts yeah
they love they love like but they love
comics if you don't bring a comic in a
lot of times they're like lot of times
I'm not [ __ ] interested like I don't
have much to talk to about I had Lindsey
Pelisson you know that is Lindsey
payless I think I'm saying it right
she's an Instagram model okay and I met
her I followed her I saw the pictures I
saw that yeah that's beautiful yep a
meter and I go like an idiot I just go
we should podcast then not realizing up
[ __ ] hair talk to her for an hour yeah
and then I have her in and she was
[ __ ] amazing that's great she was so
interesting I was like a knob like holy
[ __ ] and i even i mean i'm actually kind
of looking into doing alive she was to
be a morning show TV host on display
reason Kelly so I was like bucket a book
and theatre and we'll do a morning show
will do i do a call in sick to work show
will do a morning show dude that is by
the way the most genius show i'veseen
put together that he does on the road
I've heard of it I don't know what it is
i can ask more about it oh it's it is uh
you meet you at the club yeah i do i go
in i do radio see what was happening was
I was going in and I was drinking at
radio every time I went in radio
everyone's like the machines heerlen
screwing controls like I never have said
no taboos so I'm like okay I was just in
a radio station I think like two weeks
ago I think it was like I was like in
philly or something or something I've
got a fireball
I go as Christ you're here and they all
started laughing yeah I know like yeah
that's that's his mic right when I did
presidency blast there was like two
people that were like by the way were
only here in studio because our dream to
do a shot with you yeah like dream
achieve hahaha I was only dreams you're
gonna do right now I was I was doing so
much radio and I would go in and I would
be drinking on radio yeah I said Elliot
the morning was the first one I said it
to I said um I can't just wish I could
just go right to the club and do a show
and have everyone call in sick to work
yeah and I think Elliot was like that
that would be a great show name and I
was like yes yeah good and so I call up
Elliot the first time I just called in
and I said hey we're into a call in sick
to work show and it's sold out like 20
minutes Wow the last one sold out in a
minute like they sell out is so [ __ ]
quick here's the problem you only make
like 5 grand so you fly into a [ __ ]
City and just make 5 grand in your bail
not everyone's rolling pug here's a lot
of money but no it is yeah but if you
stayed up for a weekend you make more
money yeah but I'm not going to charge
anyone more than 20 bucks I feel like
that's a ripoff you know and then the
other thing is it cannibalizes my
material so like I go to DC and then
there's 270 people that have seen the
hour that I'm working on that I'm going
to bring back to DC and do a weekend
with right right I'd like to make a live
show I'm doing something very different
i'm doing a call in sick to work show on
the wild west comedy fest thing yeah how
many thing well yeah a lot less common
festival well yeah well it went [ __ ]
what days you gonna be there I'm there
for thursday friday saturday sunday on
there tuesday wednesday and i believe
thursday cuz i have to go to Vermont oh
yeah that's I've always wanted to go to
that things like that's the one thing
that I was like if I I'll tell you two
things very candidly yeah if I could if
I had a better gauge of if I knew you
would never have said no I would have
two things differently I would have said
I would have called you and said hey I'd
like to be a part of the wild west
comedy festival way earlier because it's
been going on for like six years uh this
is the third year okay yeah but like I
definitely when that thing started I
want you back something I want my life
like I want that and I know your part
Vince in your good friends events yeah
yeah um that and I'll tell you the other
thing that I genuinely regret when you
had to sit calm I I wish that I wasn't
man enough to call you up and go Stevie
like to audition I would love to a
billion you're so calm oh but I didn't I
didn't it happened I just get
embarrassed so no no well here's the
thing that most people don't know is
that I had a list of a dozen guys that I
had worked with that I tried without
contacting them to fit them in the show
okay and so you were you were one of the
guys I proposed season two in season
three because the first season you're
just trying to get it up right once we
found out we're coming back it's like
all right now the doors are open and
because of my my fondness for you and
the drinking aspect I was at the
beginning of each season I would go in
and I'd sit with the writers and I pitch
different people like to get Leslie
Jones on was she was she she wasn't
Leslie Jones at the time obviously but
you know it took it was just pushing a
boulder up a mountain route every time
with everybody I tried to get Sebastian
on I try to get those are all brainers
but you would I was a foot Sebastian or
bill burr or so you know it just it was
one of those things where every now and
then it would work out with Caliendo all
he does all the voices and so the
writers room lights up but if they
didn't necessarily schoenherr didn't
necessarily know who the comic was I was
just constantly selling and selling and
selling so I never wanted to reach out
to my friends ago hey I'm trying to get
you on yeah cuz then if it doesn't work
out then I feel like a complete [ __ ]
but I had this list of guys i was
adamant about getting on second season
and third season constantly and it just
you know as badly as you wanted to that
believe me I wanted it to happen just as
much oh yeah I I met up with you guys
when we were shooting for travel channel
I met up with you guys and all oh yeah
the turn I was like this is something I
would have really liked look at in my
head I was like I would have loved I've
always wanted that's why i love the
Jameson tour so much and that's what the
one thing I am jealous about you guys
like I [ __ ] I am a pack animal by
Nature yeah but for some reason I'm like
I've gotten his career I'm just always
by myself don't understand that this is
my
your mansion that's okay because I
literally I was leaving for Cleveland on
Wednesday yeah i love the club but i
love my kids it's getting tougher and
tougher leave my daughter cries now all
the time when i leave my son's a year
and a half and I'm just like I remember
sitting on the couch I was taking a red
eye and just just there to me she's like
if you don't leave soon you know you're
gonna miss your flight and I just I
couldn't get motivated to get up I'm
like it's been 20 years I'm [ __ ]
drain I don't know how much longer I can
do this and then I hung out with Porter
I'd seen his hour I saw your hour and
there was like a there was like a circle
of guys I'm like you know it's like
we're all working we're all comics we're
respected as comics but we're not part
of that crew I think that it's like Nick
Kroll will always be working Mulaney
will always be working and so I was
thinking of like reaching out to a
handful of guys and creating like this
store called the industry darlings
where's just a group of four or five
comics that were road comics but it's
like you know let's just let's just tour
and have fun and split the pie instead
of all of us just going out and being
isolated every week and it just gets to
be run down so maybe like me you Porter
canon and like you know at least three
headliners will have on it sorry oh my
god oh yeah hi how are you as a puppy
Charlie yeah be nice what's up I look hi
a shirt dollar for I saw some farmer hi
baby what do you need your good give it
so even to ball a lot then you're just
trying to get kisses I love you all
right we're on a podcast idol good night
hon good seeing you can I all right send
your sister out quickly though okay keep
it going again um no but I it's funny
you say that because I would think you
immediately maybe the reason you don't
feel the need to bring it an opener or
feature because if you weren't doing
what you
do with the fans and hanging out
afterwards like then maybe you feel
lonelier but I think because you have
that maybe that's better for you know I
did the Wilbur the other good leave in
January and uh and um it it's sold out
and I and I was behind the stage and I
think this is the moment we feel like
yeah I'm going the right direction yeah
and all think it fake was it's just me
again no one else just me yeah yeah I
only one like no I wish I had a team
with me they were like I could celebrate
with but I go no that's just I felt
silly like going good job Bert like cuz
I'm like it's just me yeah me like it's
the one thing that like you know like
segura and I have always talked about it
like doing doing dates together and like
yeah like Albuquerque or Montana but it
just never [ __ ] works out like that
that's why I love James and tour that
was like one of my favorite times doing
stamps all you had to do is 20 minutes
we all got paid [ __ ] tons of money
yet but we all I think everybody
inspired each other to because that was
the thing it was just like you know the
griffins going before me I [ __ ] love
him I respect him so much it's like I
don't want to drop the baton throughout
the course of this because I'm passing
its Gardell then gardels passing it to
you and you're closing and you know you
take it to another level and it's just
like you know everything just completely
influenced me to want to be a better
comic off of that Jameson too and I
think if I was just opening for like
shoemaker or something I wouldn't have
she said I but you know I mean like a
low dog that yeah it brings people out
on the road and stuff I don't know that
I would have had all those unique
experiences in such a short amount of
time because that's when I just moved to
LA and on all sudden you're getting to
see every improv and funny bone across
the country with four or five different
killers and it was like oh god this is
what it takes to be a [ __ ] headliner
Jesus Christ yeah that was a that was
the it seems like that's something I
would have gotten into maybe I you know
it's like one of those other things I
remember a long time ago me and Segura
was said to this guy that we were
touring with I think you know who he is
but am I gonna say his name son
to drama but we were like we should only
great when we get to I'll get to do a
theater tour and he was like he was like
I'd never do a theater with you guys
you're not [ __ ] famous and we're like
yeah he's like I need someone to help me
sell tickets you guys all sell tickets
and I was like oh yeah I guess you're
right jesus said in over there well and
then and then Alonzo Bodden it's a
haunted by richmond exact but i but I
just it's like yeah like I'm gel like I
know I'm jealous in the right word but
it's like are you know I it would be
cool to be like like some one thing I
loved about travel channel I gotta be
honest to do the product that I put out
wasn't the best but it was fun as [ __ ]
to do it yeah the flip was like a
mediocre show at best but it was so fun
traveling with 11 people it's like
having a band yeah and I think that's
what I always wanted in stand-up is to
have a band but and then he likes agoura
do so much together now don't you never
know just on the on podcasts is that it
or no no really I mean we just we just
talk cuz you have the competition the
competition was great was big um but
yeah like like we did rhogam together
that was a lot of fun yeah there's a lot
of fun doin rogan together we did two
days in a row we're gonna do three days
but sugars like I can't talk pocket
three days in a row we're gonna pay the
third day yeah but uh but yeah but I
yeah I don't know so funny your
positions are exactly completely
different because they're completely do
you always bring guys on the road with
you you always yeah yeah I just think
it's wrong with that pack mentality like
you to I it's like yeah I could be by
myself and I could even on Sullivan &
Son it's like you know to this day my
managers and agents gave me [ __ ] they
said you go out on that tour you make
six figures clean house take it all for
yourself in two or two or three months I
was like no I'm gonna go out I'm going
to split everything 25% with the three
other guys so it's four of us and then
Gary will get a cut too and if all of us
go out and do a good enough job and sell
the brand well enough it'll sell the
show that will sell the show was [ __ ]
brilliant and so that was I was always
like let's have a team mentality not a
you know an individual and look it was
probably stupid of me
we should have gone out and sold my my
name out there a little more because it
definitely I definitely took a step back
during and after the show there was this
you know because it just it really
affected my career in in not a good way
how so um I think that there was like at
the time you got to remember like TBS is
doing some single cams now and Angie
Tribeca but at the time there was this
tyler perry label that gave people kind
of the heebie-jeebies and like that's
the tyler perry network and so then you
gotta sit come on there and as great as
it was of an experience it was [ __ ]
awesome was the greatest there's still
that like perception of brand i guess
amongst executives and everybody like
jfl never did it three years stand-up
comic own TV show three other standups
they never invited us uh late night talk
shows never did one never did one to
promote you the thing and then i had a
third hour special coming out the third
season so it's like a double lame it's
like everything I've worked where I felt
like was garnered towards that gearing
towards that one year nothin [ __ ] do
you remember when Kirk Chicago comedy
festival was going on with that JFL and
it was sponsored by TBS yeah that was
the first year I should I got on the
show like to get on anybody again wonder
festival that TBS was was doing really
it was it was absolutely crazy and after
after the third season got canceled you
know so we're not coming back for fourth
and then after year you did three
seasons did three seasons I have worried
about I talked to Roy about that yeah
about that feeling that there's a
feeling that I didn't realize all men
have of this one of job ends or I mean
you know technically a fire in this
business but yeah it feels a lot it
looks like getting fired it feels like
getting fired yeah they're not did you
say we're choosing not to move forward
with the project you're like yeah okay
that's a nice way of saying you're fired
yeah um but it is there is a real
there's a connective tissue that all
grown men feel having lost a job that my
friend lost his job he just came up to
me and I and travel channel had not
would not move forward it would travel
channel with whatever and so I knew the
feeling and I'm in therapy I'm talking
about
it I talked to Roy and ruin to the
feeling was telling me it's like a loss
like a death yeah and then and then I
was I said to Royals like I really want
to talk to Steve about casinos you don't
strike me as someone who spends too much
time on emotion you just go [ __ ] it like
what's the next project yeah I mean
there was definitely that you know I'm
good at compartmentalizing all that
stuff but I think when you have a third
season and then you have a third hour
and it seems like the industry doesn't
care it seems like people aren't coming
out and you're just putting your
investing so much into these projects
and you're not seeing any uh any
kickback from it then you know I almost
quit stand up about a year after that
because it was just like it seems like
you're putting all this work in and
nobody gives a [ __ ] so it's like well
what the [ __ ] you doing it for then and
and and going out on the road became
definitely a job and that lasted for a
good month or two but then you know you
just pull your boot and pull yourself up
by the bootstraps and scope [ __ ] it
don't take a look the next record I just
remember this there was I think I think
Sullivan was ending after three seasons
with or without high ratings because if
you look at their landscape almost every
show that they had men at work ground
floor all of ya well he never read it
they never renewed them beyond two or
three seasons that was it was like three
seasons and done all of the work 10
episodes we were fortunate enough on
that third season to get 13 episodes
yeah unheard of but I almost think
regardless of what the ratings were they
were good better and different I think
we were done I think they were only at
the new president came in though
everybody knew it's like we're done
that's the reverse that's the one thing
that I was I just sort of joke about
which no one no one would ever get this
on the road but I wrote a joke about
what it's like to get a new president in
the network and I was like you know
amazing that as for the group of
liberals that they are they sure act
like Saddam Hussein because I just go in
there like I'm gonna call off names I
murdering people yeah I want you to
murder them with me if you don't murder
them with me on murdering you yeah and
it
really and I went through [ __ ] four
presidents at five presidents a Travel
Channel Jesus and every time I just was
like you just watch people it was just
like a like a massacre yeah and new
president and it was I mean if I had I
had I've been fired from travel channel
I think three times four times right
just always fire than they they were
like [ __ ] we need them and then like in
China deal and only once did I not know
my deal get renewed immediately yeah
like every I got tire fired up for every
single birth concur that ever aired
that's crazy I got fired up for the
first one I got fired after the second
one I got fined up to the third and what
was the reason for them firing you [ __ ]
him I don't know idea I mean I got fired
three times on the same show 53 times
when you get fired that second time is
almost laughable Chino they're gonna
bring you back or you don't you still
don't know no as a third the second time
I was like I was like okay like the
first time it was there was a new
present yes he did not like me and she
told me that split me to DC to tell me I
don't like you yeah and I was like Jesus
back to the airport I i was with by the
way i was with two guys who were about
to lose their jobs they didn't know it
but she flew me out there and said
Charlie Parsons and Matt Butler and and
and she was like I do not like you I
don't like anything about you I googled
you and everything I find about you
makes me dislike you more and I was like
and I remember this guy tony parsons
going this meeting is not going so good
right why like what is her endgame in in
even communicating that to you was there
to tell me that that should make make
sure that I knew she didn't like me
Jesus Christ it is awful is really weird
the guy that he brought in to to replace
Charlie Parsons i think was came out he
doesn't know that I know this but
everyone's the network the state of the
network liked me yeah and he came in and
there was a big poster of me and the
thing his first day and he was like oh
ok roller coaster he's like we will not
be putting this idiot and [ __ ] like this
on our network and I was and pointing at
me and literally three people called and
I just give me a heads up don't trust
Fred yeah it's like really and they're
like do not touch trust Fred yeah it's I
was like really like he just mocked you
in front of everyone he doesn't like you
and then of course what happens a lot of
times these networks is the day they
have a list of ideas that they are going
to put their thumbprint on the network
and i'll tell you right now and berg
conquer has been canceled three times
and it's it's aaron again on travel
channel yeah yeah so they started we
enter nick said it's a bunch of clips
from viral and birth conquer yeah but
yeah their area I love I walked in and I
was watching birth conquer by the way
they buried this season they not wanted
to air they buried it no promotion and
then and then ila my youngest is
watching it today I go why would it be
airing but isn't weird so you're saying
that they were telling you this right to
your face right but the flip side of it
is which Steven I see all the time is
that you'll go into these clubs and they
will literally be swinging off your
balls the entire weekend like weekends
great numbers are great so happy to have
you boom boom boom you get back to LA on
Monday that guy was a dick it was a
slowest weekend we've ever had he was a
pain it like I see it like all the time
from people who go out and they they're
just swinging along throughout the
weekend waiting for you to leave you
know I man this is going to be so inside
baseball but like I had I can't even
talk about it this is probably like yes
I have so many I didn't realize how many
how much people didn't like me until I
started selling tickets and then I went
oh sweet I don't think you ever liked
like but i but I mean executives [ __ ]
across the board you know so far not
comics though I mean whatever is the
google comics I've never come across a
comic that's been like her to dig but I
laughs even saying it it's like this I
know people walk in your car burn
I got like like some be real honest yeah
Sakura has not like people and told them
I'm [ __ ] like you like there's a
stairs a very like famous story about a
club you went to we found out the
manager was dating the guy that she
hired to host and feature for and seguro
found out and confronted them and then
told everyone I'll never work that
[ __ ] club again anyway who's getting
paid by like 1,500 bucks for the weekend
yeah I'm in my head going what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you what how do you have
any [ __ ] self esteem to do that like
I would be like oh great week Morris
right this is ben morris this is a nice
guy but sugar and him will never get
along ever yeah and it was and I was
like blown away that he has a balls to
be like [ __ ] Toledo let me tell you
something that that chain would probably
give him a hundred percent of the door p
dupa toledo know yeah like he just would
love to and so it's really thought like
and then I just I feel like I don't know
it I don't it I don't know the right way
to say it like once you start selling
tickets then you realize what like I
don't think they ever like did it they
weren't my family like I was I was
invested so much in people like I was
like I can't like Doc ran a funny bone
yeah in Dayton and I was like we're
close were buddies and then he gets
fired and I like I'm like I'm spoken to
him since right I put no but I saw him
every once a year so I'm once a year I'd
hang out with him I go to [ __ ] theme
parks with his kids yeah you know it's
like remember we used to like like get
in at the Hollywood improv and you'd be
like okay cool Matt comon the we're
buddies yeah and and then he just leaves
me like [ __ ] right I got a [ __ ]
become a new friend with somebody yeah I
just and thank God matcom and now owns a
bunch of clubs yeah but it's like I
don't know um well my buddy Lee Levine
has the greatest story you basically
years and years ago was good friends
with Warren member warren who used to
run the irvine improv years ago yea
years ago he was one of the original
managers that I remember he got him with
Warren and Warren said hey listen I want
you to be our new house MC I want your
one
comedy classes all this other stuff I
just that's my goal for you Lee calls me
up all stoked is that the other thing it
was like Lehigh bad news for you I just
found out Warren got fired for sexual
harassment and and not only that they
were bringing in Frank Kelly who I was
friends with and I said I got even worse
news for you Frank wants me to do all
that [ __ ] right left Emily's [ __ ]
love it's love it yeah yeah and I thank
god Dan stuck around that's the but you
know like Dan like Dan's my friend but
then like I say that i would say that's
a today's enzyme known him so long yeah
but then like New Year's Eve I guess I
get this offer I wish I can tell you the
exact numbers yeah I'll just say it I
can't even do fake I'll say it like this
ok so they're not even no correlation I
got an offer to do Seattle for one
dollar it's not one dollar but you got
one dollar right but i'm only making
fifty cents on the road so I'm like [ __ ]
I don't my new york area newseum i'll do
it and so I go to a party errands
errands a party for being at the improv
for 20 years laughing we're at the party
were all drinking and my managers like
and my manager agents like you can get
more for nears that's all I'm telling
you and I was like I don't know I it
seems like a solid offer so I see Dan as
a friend I could dan what would i get
for New Year's like you think $1 good
need to go I give you five dollars I
give me five dollars and he's like yeah
that's what I pay you and I was like
dude give any openings he's like yeah I
got Oxnard you wanted to Oxnard I go for
five dollars he's like [ __ ] yeah I was
like great I may be made him fifty cents
at the door that was when they papered
it God sorry any people are getting
three tickets like instead of buy
champagne this is [ __ ] I guess what
doesn't know they're like where do you
want any beers if you're like the same
scenario with one of the clubs right
we're basically the avocado what it
disgustingly low and you're like I'll
just a whole new year's eve and all of a
sudden things on the money oh yeah thats
I say yeah I've had the I've had exactly
that happened where you feel bad because
somebody's you know somebody's paying
you a great amount and then I've had
other times where you know you get
low-balled especially new years and I
was like I'm not doing that that's
salting offer I was like I gotta do it
at least for twice that and then feel
like I've never been that guy I've
always been like all do it for that yeah
I I countered at twice and they go huh
it was it wasn't even like you know I'm
gonna walk away it's just like I just
counter they go all right sure right it
was a item doubled it it's crazy so
who's your who's your manager now Kara
Baker who's that she works with Avalon
okay yeah now you've also been confident
to leave managers I never had that I've
always been like if they want me I'll
stay with them yeah I just left I left
CA after you know I you know when you're
when you're a kid you're young and
you're coming up you're like CA that's
it's the best agency and then you
finally get there you're like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] I just left going to W on me I left
them right so for all the people that
are just like oh my god if CAA were my
agency I would have shipped by the ass
and meanwhile people are leaving them
jumping ship just as quick but I tell
you my favorite see a story yeah so we I
think we're all at CAA mostly because a
frosty right is that what brought you
there no actually left frosty to go to
CAA and then frosty and and it was it
was when I got Sullivan & Son and I
still gave him a cut of Sullivan & Son i
sent it to frosty because i was like
your big part of helping me achieve this
and I still gave him a cut and uh I was
he was really like like you know
appreciative of that because I was rated
him I love frosty yeah so I'm I am NOT
happy at CAA I'm with their with them
and we do what we do a meeting like a
horseshoe round shoot table meeting
where you go via satellite to New York
offices were there in the horseshoe yeah
and it's everyone to each other and I
get in there and frostys it with matt
blake and MF lake and frosty I think
we're in New York at the time and like
all right well everyone's here this guy
I went to college with tom youngs
they're like ah he's an agent there I'm
like this is one talking about this is
my [ __ ] team yeah and I was like all
they got to do is not [ __ ] this up like
not say something ridiculous so this
girl comes in I don't know who what her
[ __ ] name was but she sits down she's
like by the way so this is my I second
season of birth conquer and I just
signed a deal with travel channel I was
go shooting and designed to deal with
travel channel to do for a three-year
deal scroll comes in she goes so well
all right let's start it and she goes I
think our number one goal is to get you
on television this year I'm like I watch
it and saw steak forgets he's on camera
yeah it goes oh [ __ ] and then and then
Rian's over to Matt Blake yes where's it
is here maintain that birds on travel
channel and that goes okay actually yeah
I know frosty I we go see you and he's
like ah and then she was like and then
there's poor girl just [ __ ] proceeded
to create the biggest shitshow I've ever
been a part of and I literally said I'm
leaving CAA wow she [ __ ] it up that
bad she was like yeah but you don't
wanna be on travel channel MOS be on
travel channel I go what I do I'm on
there I just I'm negotiating a
three-year deal bro hey one listen I
could I tell you guys who I am and you
can just watch everyone scrambled no one
knew anything about me no one cared
anything yet they were like it was like
[ __ ] I was the girl I made for your
agents and they were my agents and they
are your agents at the time than my
funky and I was like and I call I got on
I got out of that meeting a frosty was
calling me immediately it's like dude
dude okay I understand you have to fire
CA for acting do not fire us for touring
[ __ ] you know I could do a great job and
I was like and then I went into UTA and
Chris Hart who's like they've got these
gallon alderman and Haldeman Chris hard
all these max call these guys that were
like kind of studs you like me [ __ ] yeah
and then the first thing he said was
dude I love your [ __ ] podcast and I
want huh I remember saying to the CIA a
podcast and like who cares about
podcasting and I was like right now I
guarantee you they do yeah I guarantee
you they'd love a piece of my [ __ ]
money so but I'm talking so much [ __ ] on
this [ __ ] podcast I feel horrible but
frosty knows I love them and I love all
those guys yay but that also comes with
a tenure in this in this business it's
not like you're you're young and naive
and you're trying to be everybody's
friend it's just like know you've earned
the right to go you know what I've I've
made some great relationships have had
some bad relationships and there's
nothing wrong talking about it yeah I
and yet like you I was always shocked
when you wanted to when you I felt like
you and Matt started the head waited for
him to leave levity yeah
and then and then I didn't go and then
you like I I'm leaving that I was like I
I was like I wish I had that I wish I
had that you have it Segura has it like
BRR has it I've got this [ __ ] like
Gary and I probably the same thing where
we're like like just happy to be here
like so can I get to do stand-up like
yeah oh [ __ ] it's a weakness i think you
know i will say this is what's great
nice to work with Mitch may tell a lot
too and this is what's great about Steve
like whenever they the club starts
[ __ ] me around like if I call and try
to get information about the hotel or
where I'm staying like if they start
messing with me like Steve just jumps in
and just takes care of it like just yet
we are at Charlie good nights in raleigh
and the manager twenty-two-year-old
didn't know what the hell she was doing
didn't return one phone calls like I'm
not doing the open mic on Wednesday like
I'm working there this weekend and you
know it's amazing to me just because
they just don't care you know but but
then you go that's what that's what okay
that is what that is what bums you out
is I care so [ __ ] much about my
career yeah and just there are so many
people that really genuinely don't care
the biggest problem I had with food with
producers that I worked with on travel
channel often was that a lot of them
didn't really care I mean by the way
they line 0 a lot of maliciousness it's
not you Dan and it's not you Paul and
it's not you but but there's a lot of it
just they didn't really care about
television you'd go what shows you watch
and like I don't want Stevie you know
then you shouldn't be allowed to make it
yeah like if you don't watch TV you
shouldn't be allowed to make it because
that you should definitely be into
television like I was in I'm into
television yeah I like TV I love podcast
that's why I said we were talking about
booking a podcast I go it's so hard
because like no one would have ever in a
million years said Dave Anthony and
Gareth Reynolds would be two amazing
guests yeah they just would have been
like what oh damn broadcast what dude
they're the number one downloaded
podcast I have yeah the number one and
the other one is ari and Steve run is
easier number those two are the two dos
dos downloaded yeah there would be a lot
of people to be like huh right mm-hmm
but and that's and but the thing is I
care and like I really genuinely care
but man that drives me nuts and that's
the other thing that I don't know
that people call me cause you just don't
give a [ __ ] but their surgeon I think
more of them that don't give a [ __ ]
because again if you say to ten comics
what are your favorite clubs to work
across the country hilarities is always
coming up yeah I mean that's why you go
to Nick as you know there is wrong or
Tony baldino in Chicago and it's like Oh
iris is what it's like to be a performer
right yeah this is what it's like to be
treated like you're in show business and
then all of a sudden the perception of
that Club changes and you're like I'm
giving it a hundred and ten percent as
opposed to maybe ninety five percent in
Toledo or whatever the [ __ ] it is but
yeah I mean I always always care and I
always want to do a show because those
people work hard a week you want to give
him a great show but sometimes the vibe
in the club permeates from the manager
down and it just like all right you just
gotta [ __ ] batter through this
weekend and just hope for that was to
talk made Todd glass crazy he was he'd
go to clubs and they just didn't care
yeah and he'd be like hold on guys you
know you're not paying attention what
music you're playing before I go on
stage like a new just what do you like
plant like and it's amazing those little
attention to details really change
everything yeah I got when we were doing
the last season of triple if I was like
I was like hey guys I'll tell you what
you'll get to do everything I'm gonna do
because like we you know we'd like and I
said so fine stuff you want to do like I
said it to the preachers what do you
want to do and like there's a lot like a
handful of our producers on that show
that bucking really gave a [ __ ] yes
they're like [ __ ] man i wanna go swimmin
great white sharks and then like [ __ ]
find the best one cuz you'll get to do
it oh i'll tell you what we'll shoot
until we got it and then everyone and
the crew gets to do everything that
we're doing yeah it's an all sudden
everyone gave a [ __ ] they're like oh
[ __ ] then let's definitely [ __ ] in our
go bungee jumping I want to go jumping
off the world's tallest mountain I can
so I don't know it I in spite I got in
trouble with my school my daughter
school because uh I was a safety valet
and these people parked illegally and I
yelled at them and one they were doing
both teachers and then they were started
crying and then the principal came to me
and say hey we got to find a new way to
do this and the teachers were there and
I literally was like I told her I go Hey
ladies I can stop caring about where you
park all
a lot faster than I can make you care so
I just don't ever help again [ __ ] you
know what way all right that way to go
way to go dummy we got fired and then
[ __ ] the other two ones apologize to
me and they're like yeah it was I
shouldn't park in a handicap spot yeah
but we always Stephen I always say this
every time you go to a club that you
ever been to in a year it's always a
different staff I mean it's very rare
that it's the same manager oh no I mean
it's different people all the time and
Steve knows one of my biggest pet peeves
which drives me up a [ __ ] wall is
when they bring me up from the back the
the the sound guy and it's the worst
[ __ ] intro it's like what how am I
supposed to get excited about going on
right now it's like it really it drives
me I mean Stephen I've seen it so many
times where you're like that's the
energy you're throwing behind this [ __ ]
does it mean it's awful it's it's a had
a girl the feature for me or hosted for
me at a college and she was so nervous
as he was like okay okay before before I
go up there it's Kreischer right don't
ya it's just cry sure Christ you're
quite sure cry sure no n-no n-no there's
no n cry sure ok ok great so that she
goes up so does your such thing all
right you guys ready to put your hands
for the man of the hour you guys know
him you love him put your hands together
for Brent Chrysler a buddy of mine years
ago when i started doing stand-up in San
Francisco he worked with Zach
Galifianakis and that guy couldn't have
butchered Zach's name six different ways
every show Zach Galifianakis back like
every show he [ __ ] it up and just
couldn't in their Emperor q lo said he
finally got it right and he was so
[ __ ] excited like a little kid was so
bad at [ __ ] hosting when we got like
when Ida hosted the Hollywood improv I
would tend his day I have a hard time
remembering I hosted it the story of the
night Ferrari show and I [ __ ] could
not say the girls name yeah she told me
five times and it seems like a good
golfer Loni love ya even our baffled
about this it maybe you have an opinion
about this I find so many guys that live
in LA so many comics that work the roads
or features they you know maybe headline
see clubs around the country I'm baffled
how people make a living in LA and
survive because I I know what I make and
and I'm certainly we're renting it apart
like I just don't know I can't hide to
how people do it I can't believe when I
look at the cars people have I go I
always go like how do you afford that
like like like do that it's so funny i
think there's also like let's go to the
store you see someone who's like not
doing the road or not to intellivision
yeah cargo wheat how do you make your
money like yeah like that [ __ ] blows
me away like my gardener and my maid
both went to Hawaii this this past
Christmas me panem said very much know
if you can hear darkness I could double
dip my father's been gone all month I
bar guard have been gone all month he's
in [ __ ] Hawaii for a month really and
by the way doesn't even do a [ __ ]
good job we fired our old one is that
kind of all the [ __ ] you have bad then
this one but I just I mean literally I
always look around it like buddies of
mine did that just work once a month
maybe they're you know working B&C rooms
I'm like I know what my rent is I know
my car like how do you guys do it how do
you pull it together got specially in
this city I've always come was
fascinated like I would love to know by
the way Colin Jost is an interesting guy
because you were within the Montreal one
year and you're sitting talking to him I
mean you were like hey Burton I came
over and I think he was like hi how you
doing and I was like how to Steve know
the guy from SNL and you're like and
then and then you just said you used to
feature for you yeah yeah I met him
years ago Neal Brennan when Colin was
just staff writer Neal was friends with
Colin because Neal's always hanging out
with everybody Diana Collins like yeah
I'm looking to do more stand-up I'm Mike
you can do the road with me if you want
here's really I gave him some dates the
next day next thing I know we're in West
Palm korab or fort lauderdale at the
Hard Rock greatest time kids great works
hard and then every I think for three
summers went during his hiatus on SNL
he's coming open for me and then he got
you know each year you know then he got
the head writers gig and then the minute
he got uh he got update is like all
right we're not you're not opening
congratulations yeah but couldn't be a
nicer guy like works his ass off and he
was part / special in New York the one
before the one yeah the champion
champion he he actually opened up and
did time it was just before he was about
to do because I taped it like january
second yep and his first week on SNL was
like the next right really yeah so it's
pretty cool well let's talk about your
first I know you gotta you gotta run out
of here to go to playoffs yeah I'm
playing hockey but it's a playoff game
otherwise i would just stay but um what
Gary can you hang or do you have to
leave too I'll probably go okay all
right cool he's got to start gardening
so this potential areas Saturday night
Friday night nine o'clock eastern eleven
o'clock nine o'clock nine o'clock yeah i
was at eleven o'clock right i think
there's a ten o'clock actually that was
11 11 to 10 2pm okay I don't know nine
o'clock my hotel today I'm generally
good yeah so pretty pumped about it Gary
opened yeah I got to do the warm-up for
it but the warm-up yes yeah yeah I felt
like this little nice niche I've been
doing a lot of well I I don't have my
own special but I've done warm up for a
bunch of others let's just be grateful
yeah about it's a good game do they did
they record you at all I don't think so
i should okay yeah of course you do i
asked i asked schouler to record
everybody set since the cameras are
there and everything yeah and then uh a
week after my cake we emailed the cliff
Stoll the guys because it was you and
the earth Reynolds open in bill crawford
and bill crawford did the second one and
where did you shoot it in a chicago ok
lincoln hall and I said can you guys
send him the clips and they go oh we
meant to tell you we didn't do it we
forgot to like how the [ __ ] did you
forget to just turn the cameras on and
just film these guys and give him a
great page I mean it would've been a
great tape for cameras yeah it's been
awesome they just double punched yes I
think I've double punched a lot yeah it
really it looked and looked great I
remember when we were setting it up in
the afternoon when you're kind of doing
the run through it just like it seem
like you're like is this gonna come
together like it's just like you walked
in and looked like somebody was just
moving into a house like yeah it was
everywhere there were chairs everywhere
just like you know nothing was done and
then we literally came back like four
hours and like you know people were
being sad the lights were down the
lights were on the backdrop I was like
oh wow this looks great but the end the
the end bid is different than most stand
up like our specials it's a different
ending I had like a [ __ ] joke that
[ __ ] killed and I was it was my
closer but as we're getting closer like
my mom and dad are introducing me my
brother I talk so much about my life the
back half is all these lessons I wanted
still upon my children as they grow
older and like advice to younger people
from somebody's 42 somebody's 20 it was
like it was like a really sweet kind of
like and then I was like am I just going
to end this on a [ __ ] jokers and
kills and so a month out I worked on the
ending bit and it wasn't until the third
week it worked and then I had two weeks
to really hone down on it and memorize
it but it was still so raw and it was it
really is a message to my children that
I got emotional before we uh before I
launched into it and in the hour I God
the motion like I cracked for a second
because it was it was really raw was
really earnest and I really was seeing
my children as I'm launching into this
and and I cracked and we almost took it
out but I said keep it in because it's
an authentic moment and it's something
you don't see in most stand-up specials
and if comics watch it I don't get
crucified for but it's like [ __ ] it I'm
talking about my kids yeah I do get
emotional about my kids so uh I really
love it and this kid jamiah who plays
guitar he opened up for me he's a blues
guitarist so he opens that he's the
music that bleeds into it and he's he's
like this seventeen-year-old Katie's
this blues prodigy and just shreds and
then when we were getting there I was
like why don't we have jamaya Rogers do
music underneath this last bit and so we
rehearsed it that day at the taping
foolish and I said jamaya can we try
this out he said yeah so we talked it
out I did it once he played guitar
Schuler was on the stage with us he goes
I wouldn't do it I go okay and then he
goes but you know what hold on
on stage let me hear it let me go to the
back of the room so he goes in the back
of the room he watches it I go jamiah
what you might do it again yeah so we do
it and then as soon as it ended Schuler
goes absolutely you got to do it you
guys do what your Maya so that the the
actual taping when you see it it's only
the third time we ever did it I mean
technically it's kind of like the first
time because it was in front of an
audience and stuff so it's just one of
those things where I felt like it kind
of came together I don't want to tile
tell what it is but it's it's like a
message for my kids I you know I hope I
hope it goes over well we'll see I don't
know I would have rather heard the blows
up to me I'd oh by the way up i get
teared up in my [ __ ] joke this is a
good one guys your inner liner bynum
everything that i didn't realize it was
I didn't realize that my kids would see
it one day I've just recorded it and
there's like I talk about my wife
farting during oral sex yeah I'm [ __ ]
no concept no wherewithal to be like
yeah one day my kids are gonna be like
right about what I in my special I was
very aware of it that's why I didn't end
on the thing I was going to end but I i
mentioned something in it of like one
day five years and I daughter's gonna be
in junior high school and she's gonna
see her dad like you know jerking off
all these guys below it's like my dad is
it work yes he doing he's blowing and
[ __ ] guys getting about [ __ ] he's
working looks like I'm I this my last
hour I made fun of my daughter's
non-stop yeah I just think about how
done they are and I'm still doing it my
new stuffs all about how [ __ ] stupid
they are yeah but there I do I showed it
to Georgia I showed it a bit about I'll
about it put her finger in the ass but
in a dog's mouth yeah and Georgia is
howling laughing she's like oh my god
you can let I will see this
that's funny yeah it's great though it
also provides I think you come from a
place of love I mean I think there's
some comics that come from a place where
they are jaded and their little
disturbed but I just knowing you and I I
think that's going to provide a great
time capsule for your daughter's 20 30
years from now she'll be able to show
her kids that go grandpa was [ __ ]
awesome check the [ __ ] out you know what
I did for islets of issues i'm sick and
i started reading mitch hedberg jokes to
her ah there she was howling fest
graphing she was like wait he does what
you do yeah it's like yeah little better
but kind of yeah but uh that's awesome
and I'm really I'm really excited to see
it Thank You Man everybody which is much
for having us by the way to I really
appreciate it it's a list of it great to
finally get down here anytime I mean you
know if you guys ever want to do this
anytime just call me these are always
good for me because it's a effortless I
think the next time we do it we should
all over here yeah game I would do it
but I think me you and maybe we get
Garrett down here let me have like yeah
we just yeah yeah oh that's I'm in for
that sure Gareth will sit there get my
dog come though he'll be gardening Jesus
can I bring my dog he texted me goes you
have a backyard I was like who doesn't
have a [ __ ] backyard yeah yeah no I
didn't realize that i said that i said
to my wife I go that's what I have a
[ __ ] backyard what is he yeah I think
you probably is bringing the dog went oh
did she know that immediately yeah oh
that's funny yeah and so then i said you
have a backyard in a front yard you're
like that's a weird question yeah and
then he was like my dog has separation
anxiety yeah totally and I know I go
like we should introduce the two dogs on
a play in the backyard and lan goes
you're gonna introduce priscilla to a
dog with separation anxiety it's like
holy [ __ ] idea oh that's funny and so
I was like oh good call good call by the
way i just want to mention a really
quick story about you like one of the
first time you and I ever worked
together years ago at the tampa improv i
was checking in somewhere ran into
somebody and I said it was work at the
improv asked me with who and I said you
and the mother said my daughter is a big
fan of his and all of his work on the
travel channel the girl was like a 13
year old girl
I remember texting you and you said hey
bring them over to the hotel i'll say hi
to them and you were staying like right
at the street I remember you went over
there or they came over to see you and
you must have spent a half an hour with
ugh because I was really remember that
clear say cuz back when they shouldn't
matter to me either could get me now I
got fired from travel channel [ __ ] 3
times I could be five yeah yeah I
remember the girl was like why is he
staying at a Red Roof Inn gave me a hug
each other who you smell like I thought
you'd smell like everything that's funny
yeah well alright so the special is this
Friday at ten at 9pm 19 Showtime it's
called tell the joke tell the damn joke
a hell of a damn joke his name is steve
byrne he's one of my favorite human
beings in the world and his co-host is
some guy named Gary an acquaintance of
Steve yeah last call with carson daly
back in two thousand eight my grandma
actually did live at Gotham twice and I
did the executive more years apart for
years apart more years apart my readout
them because I have any new stuff I
didn't want to ask him if I could do the
same stuff cuz I knew they would say no
we do at the one time what was the one
time we work together and some guy came
out and he's like you're the coals guy
yeah and you're like yeah yeah yeah
Ralphie you step on my ass about that
you think I would come up to be like hey
you called me Kol's back in two thousand
three yes I did you write a [ __ ] joke
can endure the cold guy absolutely
awesome well thank you guys very very
good luck in your game tonight thank you
fighting alright alright guys that was
the podcast I'm here with my wife no I
guess the podcast is still going we're
going we're talking black sails black
sails can you do it yes what do you want
to say I'm upset what because i did not
like that finale talk a little louder
maybe i did not like that finale i was
very disappointed we've clearly we
haven't podcasted about black sails for
over a month since before we went to
London so there are many many many
things have happened in many episodes
since we last talked about it on the
podcast it's got good a lot of it was
really great and then the series finale
happened and it was not happy not happy
I was [ __ ] lame it was great it was
great because it was great because the
build-up was was you got to know you got
to know the complicated relationship
between John Silver and Captain Flint
Flint and you found out that you that
one like there it was just a chess match
of watching the two and then Flint stole
the treasure and then it was just going
on and on and on then it's everyone by
the way everyone sent me post like Bert
you know this is all about gay pirates
right and I was like yeah I know that
I've been watching the show provide all
well the problem that I had was if this
is a prequel to Treasure Island right
when they show up again in Treasure
Island they're all in kind of bad shape
so I kind of wanted them left in bad
shape and the only thing we didn't know
we in Treasure Island it's assumed that
captain Flint is dead right but I kind
of wanted him to be day it by the way
captain Flint's not dead it's boys
weekend boys weekend every weekend I
kind of okay i will tell you i liked so
captain Flint just so you know big con
spoiler alert I can't imagine that
you're still listen to this if you've
never watched black fails but if you're
just like sitting on a plane going you
know what I'm now just tell me at all
captain Flint was the world was the
worst pirate and the reason he was
because he just wanted to [ __ ] die he
just he had been
in love with a dude isn't the worst
pirate he was the best that's why I
meant like the worry okay call the works
like this is the worst idea that means
it's like the worst idea ever had so
that's not how I would have used that
price but whatever do you been drinking
their habit yeah whatever degree so the
reason was because he fell in love with
the dude and that was played out until
like season 2 season 3 you figured it
out you're like whoa to kind of changed
everything and then you realized oh
he'll never rest he just wants to go and
wreak havoc because they killed his
boyfriend that and he had nothing to
live for nothing to lose yeah nothing to
lose daughter live boy that's why it was
the greatest pirate that was around and
he was angry really angry they took his
dude from him and then they took his
woman from him and then he got even more
angry killed his woman by the way that
was like [ __ ] how to end a show creo
that was like the [ __ ] highlight even
to was amazing Tommy seasons they do 33
season so scenery was ok I started
episode off with like just like what the
[ __ ] who's this guy why is he there
what's going on it's I'm gettin chill
bumps guy did think this was kind of
cool turns out that John Silver instead
of killing Flint realized if he found
Flint's boyfriend he could just send
them to prison with his boyfriend and
they'd be together and happy well hold
on Flint thought his boyfriend was
killed yeah what he was wrong but he was
wrong because I guess back in the day
and corded this story there was a
plantation they sent people like his
boyfriend Thomas who was gay in their
favor Shane the family was a shame yes
they send them to this plantation where
they just worked and they never left the
plantation yeah and so silver found out
that Thomas his boyfriend was at this
plantation so he had planned on
capturing Flint and then sending him to
the plantation so he could be with
Thomas and this week I thought was lame
no you didn't he's a [ __ ] pirate he
should have been dead it was so lame i
know he ran their like saw Thomas was
like oh my god then they embraced and
then they kissed in the middle of a
plantation
17 [ __ ] whatever it was I was like
that would never happen and that is so
lame and I was so mad and then
everybody's story line got tied up with
a bow and presented on a silver tray and
their [ __ ] pirates the only person
that got what they what you like the
prerequisite prerequisite to treasure
island is Billy bones yeah he's the only
one educational place you fell off a
boat and he went back to skeleton island
and he was stranded there and in
Treasure Island he talks about having
been stranded there with other pirates
and they were eating each other and some
of them died there they didn't show any
of that like there were no other pirates
here besides Billy bones but billions
upon skeleton island which is exactly
where he says he was in Treasure Island
no [ __ ] woman that John Silver's in
love with and Treasure Island out care
didn't necessarily match anyway by the
way wait did she live in this what do
you mean does she live so she lived his
girlfriend did you fall asleep no no did
you fall asleep it like 30 minutes in
yes he found her that's why why can't
you say yes yeah yeah she found her he
found her in the McGowan calendar I
think Billy bones should have killed her
I think Billy bones should have killed
her too because that would have made
more sense and I think John Silver's
should have killed plant and left him
dead on skeleton island and then I would
have felt like it was a real it would it
would have it felt real it felt so
contrived I was so angry and
disappointed and sad and Jonathan I'm
mad about it jonathan is the creator of
black sails who probably isn't listen to
this I'm sure not that is it was really
really upset and disappointed a little
bit heartbroken because I love that show
I was such a great show and it was a
great show up until I the only thing Lee
Anne Lee got you got turned off when
they started kissing the field as a baby
no problem with gay men kissing yeah but
it doesn't fit the story it was so
against the story it was against the
whole story
I just made me so upset it was against a
time period that would have never
happened like that I don't care if
they've been separating I thought you
were dead that's not the way it would
never have happened I don't believe it
would have ever happened like that well
that's the reason I had a hard time with
Greece live I never saw a grease like
always live yeah I kept going like wait
there's black greasers yeah how come no
one's saying like how progressive is
this school that black kids and white
kids are making out the 50s in the
hallways and no one's got a fire hose
prayed at them like it's just what it
when a story changes to today's
standards well ask you to suspend your
disbelief to the point where it is not
possible to suspend it yeah that's when
it gets ruined I could not suspend my
disbelief when he saw Thomas and they
embraced like hand behind the head
romantic kissing was not any awareness
and he's on a [ __ ] Puente she's going
to use ass whipped with a whip into some
kind of the kind of writing I liked his
when paint Charles vane vein died when I
was vain doubt I was like [ __ ] and when
they kill Miranda and when they said
let's give him a reason to be afraid of
us I was like [ __ ] yeah yeah I think
that's what I was looking for in the
ending of this me too I'm for like a big
dick swinging moment it's a it's a
fantasy we're trucking we're little boys
watching pirates yeah I wanted a to be
continued I wanted to be left with wait
a minute what happened or I know where
they end up in Treasure Island how do
they get from here to there yeah I'm
feel that way I felt like tidy and tidy
and clean and not at all pirate like I
was very disappointed I know you were
and I and I am I as I wasn't as
disappointed but I I was bummed that we
it was like having a loss you know what
here's the other thing though what do
you expect the same reaction if you've
lost you remember yeah really let down
that was our show yeah and frickin we're
like huh what ah they're in purgatory
that's stupid I don't even want I don't
even like the show now the really bummed
lost was such a great [ __ ] show yes
it was
um and you know it didn't match up like
I mean it doesn't hold up to my 600
pound live which is now I like it or
main cabin or what a main cabin main
cabin builders the grand builders
builders and so what's our next show
going to be game tonight does it come
out to like July now um I don't know
that's a great that's a great point guys
if you're still listening then that is
you are the one percenters so let's
decide a show together that we can all
watch and the Annan I'll draw no I got
i'd be interested in it I can't watch
some [ __ ] show that every single way to
go there was a waste of my time so I
don't know if I if I want like a general
consensus and choosing my entertainment
time because is limited at best okay so
well we're not going to do feud no we're
not doing to your big little eyes or a
big stuff yeah no chick stuffs gonna
lose I know I don't know khadi told me
like the best show ever she's ever seen
as Friday Night Lights ever in her whole
life was friday night lights really yep
I've never seen it but she has told me
for years now that we should watch that
show my earrings are really infected I
could do bloodline we could do you have
a washing more bloodline have you
covered what's another good one that
yeah I'm not into that Kevin Spacey show
house of cards I tried that I can't get
into that had someone someone was like
are you interested in dancing with the
stars I was like know why this that's
what I mean if someone says hey looks
like what dance with the Stars I might
stab myself in the neck I can't do that
alright well we'll figure out the show
I'll take some insights just put it up
say like have you guys seen this it's
really great and if we haven't seen it
will check it out by the way this mean
this off-the-grid builders you gotta
stop watching TV while you're on the
podcast it's really you're really
distracted mmm I ya know yes you are no
God are we finished talking about black
sails I learn first yeah I said my
favorite you're sad that's okay um
alright guys well
thank you very much for this in the
podcast today i hope you enjoyed it
watch Steve Byrnes podcast or watch
Steve Byrnes our special and uh I love
you with all my heart Lee am I love you
too baby doll I don't do that I gotta
sound talk look at all
[Music]
this episode was brought to you by the
Machine
you